So
next game against Charles Mattel from
Norway
answered black six,
I had this strange pension
recently and I had no
idea, well
no idea how to play it,
he just goes back
and then at some point when you always
have the farm C4 in your  Position,
it's kind of strange with the
farm T2 standing next to it,
well,
I don't know,
you don't have many ideas other than C4 C5 in the
position. I have to
admit,
he could do a runner G5 here at some point, well
I'll try if I can
can create weaknesses here
so and now I'll try this
strange move maybe then C4 b4c5 I ca
n't think of anything else here
black can but at any time
tell me five games e.g. yes I want to
exchange one with bishop F5 question is
whether I can prevent that with knight F3
In any case, everything should be very slowly,
yes, but I think I still have to prevent it,
so now he's going back,
yes, but he never wants to do it in that position, so
not like that, now
try this way,
I understand, so maybe I can do it
myself now  Forgive four and
getting rid of my strange bishop
wouldn't be much power either,
yes this strange formation in the
gut wing
I have to get the knight
back as quickly as possible
somehow get in there properly with knight F4 and so on
first go back again
yes black is definitely okay here
With this opening I
really have no idea
how to play it,
yes if the knight plays F4 what do
I
really do G3 maybe to
kick it first,
well you can't leave a figure standing for a long time
then in any case
I don't know what exactly
maybe he wants to support F5 so that one
can be supported,
well, okay, but that's part
of the plan anyway,
swapping a bit of something,
it's not that terrible
if he shows up there,
so
I also have the e49 field
so yes, that was somehow clear  only he
somehow gets everything there now
so first of all cover the critical fields here
again
so now I could send the sound back with G3
why does
F3 just hang there
my god my god played great
yes I play strong now
too slow and too bad
God  oh god oh god lost straight away yes
god against his stupids well yes yes yes yes yes
you can move so
he probably has
others too but if
you just don't have a move
F2 you can then give up a tone D2
what is he doing here now
Tom the three  or whatever the thread, that's
enough
today